you just voice stuff on the Mandalorian
Star Wars Starkiller and Force Unleashed
game series Darth Maul uh Palpatine and
Clone Wars and Rebels it's unbelievable
how why can't I get one audition for a
damn Star Wars dude it's so look that
was because a friend of mine uh okay so
the Force Unleashed was a video game
project and George Lucas and the team
there decided they're like you know I
don't know how this happened but at some
point someone said and let's pretend
like it was George right so here goes
yeah all right you know what you should
do for video games it's uh you should uh
you should hide that's him a guy who
looks like the he doesn't just sound
like the part but he looks like the part
and you can we can use our ilm
technology to put him in the game
that'd be interesting and someone
decided yeah that the characters needed
to be played by people who looked and
felt like him in the way that the
character would walk and everything
would be dictated by the actor which was
not done in video games back in 2007. so
uh my buddy says you gotta send me your
headshot and you're real
and then he slipped it into the pile and
I happen to look like how they wanted
the character to look you know they they
this artist created this piece of art
that looked somewhat like me and then
they that's the headshot looked like
what they wanted to look like then I
came in for an audition and that's when
me being a Star Wars nerd helped because
there was a scene we were doing and the
character's supposed to start in the
scene meditating assembling his
lightsaber with the force and he's
meditating and then he comes out of the
meditation and has the scene and I did
the scene different every time but the
meditation I always did it really tense
like you know it was just balled up in
Fists of Fury and White Knuckles and and
after a while the director's like you
know we've done this scene four times
and you've done it different
but the meditation why are you playing
it so tense the meditation you're so
you're so tense in the meditation and I
said he doesn't know how to meditate the
director's like what
he's a Sith he thinks this is how you do
it and you force the pieces together
because it's the this is my jaw the
force belongs to me so I was like Vader
would never have taught him how to find
inner peace he would have taught him to
do the opposite and when I did that I
saw a bunch of lucasfone people behind
this glass wall at the studio and they
were all starting to look at me and talk
about that you know what's he doing and
I was told that was when I got hired for
Force Unleashed so like the moment you
geeked out on what the Sith would have
taught is when you got the role and then
because of Force Unleashed Dave filoni
hired me for Clone Wars which is where
my voiceover career began basically how
many episodes of Clone Wars did you do I
can't remember it was something around
11 or something like but the thing is
whenever I was in it it was a big deal
they always made a big deal about it so
it feels like I'm in the show more than
I I was but but basically it started
with this character called the son of
mortis who they were like you want to do
Clone Wars I'm like yeah sure and
they're like it's a really cool role I'm
like I just already said yes you don't
have to say that you know whatever and
then eventually I find out that you're
like no you're playing the dark side of
the force there it says this dream world
and Anakin and Obi-Wan and Ahsoka are in
this dream world and they meet this
character named the Sun and where the
audience is going to it's going to Dawn
on them that this is actually the voice
of the dark side
trying to turn to turn everyone you know
and manipulate events and so I did that
and then after that me and Dave became
friends because we were nerding out just
kept hiring you and then eventually he
was like Hey so you know you got some
friends in lucasfilm I'm doing my Dave
impression and I got some friends and
like some so you probably know we're
gonna bring Darth Maul back I'm like
yeah I've heard he's like what do you
think about that I'm like I don't know
about that dude I don't know if that's a
good idea he's like okay well we gotta
maybe we got something for you in the
future so thanks for coming in and see
you later and I'm like oh and I didn't
make the account I'm like oh so I'm
gonna play a bounty hunter he's like
uh yeah we haven't been listening to the
conversation okay cool cool see you
later see you later I had no idea so he
calls me a year later and he's like so I
need Darth Maul can you do it and I'm
like
what
give me your best Darth Maul well so
Darth Maul from The Phantom Menace by
was voiced by Peter Sarah finowitz and
he was very at last we will reveal
ourselves to the Jedi at last we will
have Revenge so I had to use that voice
as the building block to create my Darth
Maul which has elements of both but it
goes in its own Direction you see you
know and so
um
um so it had it it had to have the sense
of Peter sarahfinowitz like that being
the younger version of the character but
eventually he the the voice takes some a
voice of its own and and um
and so Dave and I I'm Juilliard that
helped well right and what's hilarious
is that me and ralphsito my Julia are
voice and speech Guru would make Star
Wars jokes all the time so I would say
empressito it's like yes Mr Whitworth I
am your Emperor now make the vowel
sounds correctly this time you know and
it was that's what we would do so now
you know now I wish I could bump into
him and be like I have learned to use my
voice in unnatural ways that's Palpatine
is it possible to learn this power Mr
Whitwell not from a Jedi you know so
that is perfect so good Lord so the Star
Wars thing has been really fun the mall
character we have done now what feels
like countless hours